my nose please he's not going to stop
welcome
[Music]
don't forget who taught you how to fight
kid
hey youtubers is Charlie so best news
ever they confirmed Deathstroke is
coming back to arrow
Simon explain what's going on if you're
new to the channel I do Marvel and DC
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything there's even a giveaway going
on at the end of the video I'll explain
but if you thought today couldn't get
any better like we got all this new
footage from Thor Ragnarok they just
casually dropped this picture here
Stephen Amell is like seems like about
the right time to post this so oh my
gosh Deathstroke is coming back we knew
he would come back eventually but it was
a matter of scheduling and him fitting
into this story so Marc Guggenheim the
other producers teased the crazy links
that Oliver was going to go to to hunt
down and stop prometheus
this is the actual quote from them they
gave this like a couple weeks ago before
we ever knew that Deathstroke was coming
back but now it seems like that's who
they were talking about so it reads the
alliances are going to be very
surprising you're not going to believe
who Oliver's working with to defeat
Prometheus it's going to be really
emotional it's going to be all about
Oliver's family but not the family we're
thinking of right now it's going to end
in a giant explosion but not where we
think it's going to end and the
emotional punch is going to be bigger
than the actual physical part of the
bombs going off so thinking about that
in mind there's going to be a giant
explosion we're going to be in a place
that we don't think that we're going to
be in this is the title of the finale
that Marko could have just teased leann
you we are going back to the beginning
it doesn't make so much sense that
Prometheus's arc goes all the way back
to the beginning of season 1 where
Oliver started and doesn't it make sense
that all of the things that Prometheus
has been doing to Oliver have been
taking him back to the beginning the
beginning of the show the beginning of
his time as the hood - literally taking
him back to the point at which he
started on the show the opening shot of
arrow was him on the island being picked
up they said that that was where the
flashbacks would end at the end of
season 5 so we had to come back to the
island so we're building to this moment
in the past and in the present so past
and present are colliding on arrow in
the finale with all kinds of physical
and emotional bombs going off in the
background it is going to be a battle
royale with Deathstroke
Oh
the name of the island they found me on
is Lian Yu it's Mandarin for purgatory
I've been stranded here for five years
I've dreamt of my rescue every cold
black night since then for five years
I've had only one thought one goal and
survived survive and one day return home
so the actual finale isn't supposed to
air till May 24th in there implying the
desert was coming back for this finale
based on all the stuff they're saying
but he might come back before that they
didn't say if it was just going to be
one episode like they teased him at the
end of the episode right before the
finale and then he's part of the entire
finale or if it's some other episode but
he is coming back I love the way Stephen
Amell just posted this picture of the
helmet in the ground
that's because Manu Bennett probably
wasn't around it is only the beginning
Marc Guggenheim teased that there was a
bunch of other surprise stuff that
they're going to be dropping in the
finale meaning other characters you know
the big twist teeing up what's going to
be happening at season six so a lot of
that stuff we probably won't find out
about for a while they're going to try
and keep it as secret as long as
possible but we'll start getting clues
about season six things that are
happening as we get closer to the finale
so we can start speculating then but
most of the arrow stuff this season has
been stuff that's invoked the first
season invoke the pilot so just think in
that direction most of the big Easter
eggs that I'm expecting from arrow this
season like the big characters and stuff
will be people things that they did in
the past it won't be stuff from other TV
shows but the cool thing about this and
you know Katie Cassidy coming back as a
series regular as the black siren
character for season six means that they
might try to bring new back for season
six a little bit too but before we get
ahead of ourselves let's talk about the
price the Deathstroke would extract from
Oliver in exchange for his help like
what would you say to someone after they
escaped from Lian Yu you kept them
locked up for an entire year they'd
probably been hiding out like what is
Deathstroke been doing this whole time
obviously he's still alive because he
escaped Lee Anne you during season 3 if
you don't remember what happened the
last time we saw Deathstroke was when
Oliver took Thea who was still in the
midst of her bloodlust trying to work
through it to Lee
and you to try to work through her [ __ ]
like okay we're going to do some karate
kid' training hopefully that will help
you clear your head
but because Deathstroke was being kept
in the Argus prison there they found
that he escaped they did battle never to
be heard from again until now how many
people can Oliver Queen loose for there
is no more Oliver Queen
[Music]
but we haven't met any of his children
they use the Isabel rochev character as
ravager so technically there is no Rose
Wilson
but there is a Joseph that's Jericho in
Grant Wilson exists too because we saw
him on legends of tomorrow in a
potential post-apocalyptic future what
is the uprising after I think it's just
what people call it when well when all
this happened
15 years ago he brought an army with him
he's like no I did
Slade that's the name I haven't heard in
a long time
happy now my father place got attacked
after grant willson out a queen as a
green arrow
[Music]
so that was like a darkest timeline
situation but grant willson is also the
Ravager character so that would be the
next ravager they could bring on the
show they could do an arc like that if
they ever wanted to bring Roy back or do
some Teen Titans stuff but if there was
any question for the future in terms of
season 6 season 7 however many seasons
arrow wants to go they can do more
Suicide Squad stuff they actually said
whatever ended up happening behind the
scenes with the Warner Brothers
corporate people they totally can do
Suicide Squad stuff and they have a
couple really big characters that are
locked up at Argus like King shark in
black siren they could reform the league
if they wanted to with a couple new
characters so because black siren is
going to be a series regular next year
it just gives a lot of questions as to
what they're going to be doing with
those other characters I don't know if
they'd ever do King shark on arrow
though that'd be crazy but Captain
Boomerang is teasing that he might come
back so there's a lot of Suicide Squad
stuff floating in the background but
LYLAS and control of Argus right now
because Amanda Waller's dead so let me
know how do you want them to use
Deathstroke in the future it's just a
question of the new Bennett's
availability he's a series regular on
another TV show that shoots in New
Zealand so it's just a big problem
getting him physically to the studio to
do stories but they've used the
character before without actually using
the new Bennett they just keep the
helmet on and he doesn't speak but
that's not really Deathstroke if you're
going to do Deathstroke you want it to
be Manu Bennett you want him to speak
with his voice so what's going to happen
next is is there supposed to be some
special Star Wars announcement on Good
Morning America they released this
teaser on GMA Star Wars Celebration
anniversary and she's got an
announcement you won't wanna miss
because when you hear that you'll want
to be part of this for tomorrow Luke
Skywalker and Rey together with so Star
Wars announcement forty years in the
make no idea what that's for that could
be a force for change trailer they're
going to drop that's a little bit
different from an actual trailer because
that footage is going to drop at Star
Wars Celebration later this week so
whatever ends up happening I'll be doing
Star Wars tomorrow morning and I'll post
some flash tube so a whole bunch of
awesome stuff happening this week if you
didn't remember but there is a new round
of the flash ring giveaway going on all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
congratulations to last week's giveaway
winner Robin 764 please private message
me so I can get your contact details and
you can click here to rewatch all the
crazy Thor trailer and you can click
here for my Teen Titans Judas contract
review couple problems but overall it
was a fun movie thank you so much for
watching
let's buy five I'll see you guys in the
next video